Modern mobile devices are
amazing tools for gaming.
They give you this
great experience,
right on the screen,
with tons of sensors
to capture touch and gestures to
enhance your gaming experience.
With all this
technology, wouldn't it
be great if you could
experience the fun
of playing a game in the
same room as your friends?
My name is Nathan Camarillo.
And with Google Cast games,
you can recapture that magic
of sitting down in
your house, and playing
a great game with your friends,
all on your own devices.
So what is a Google Cast Game?
A Google Cast Game enables
multiscreen game play
between mobile devices
and television.
When you combine
the biggest screen
in the house with an
amazing controller,
great things can happen.
But making a great
game with Google Cast
is more than just linking
your devices together.
So I'm here with a
few handy design tips
to help you make your game
night even more successful.
One of the most critical
points in making
a Cast Game is simply, how does
someone find and join a game?
The way to accomplish
this is to make sure
that your game can find
nearby Cast devices,
and automatically present
the user with the option
to Cast as part of
the game set up flow.
Thankfully for
you, the developer,
this is easy to enable.
Just set up the game
with the Google Cast SDK.
One thing I want you to remember
when you're making your game
is that you need to decide
where you can play your game.
If you're making a game that can
be played on the mobile device,
away from the television, we
call this a Cast enabled game.
It's the kind of game you can
play on the go, away from home,
but then connect when there's
a Cast device available.
If the game can only be played
as part of the Google Cast
experience, we call this
a Cast required game.
No matter which Cast
technology solution
you choose for your game, these
are two universal concepts
that apply to all games.
Now let's look at a
spectrum of game controls.
Abstract controls
interacts with action
on the screen via
some other mechanism,
such as motion,
or touch anywhere.
Think of a sports game,
or a driving game.
I can swing a racket
or a baseball bat,
or use the device
like a steering wheel.
The power of this
type of control
is that everyone intuitively
knows how to do these actions,
and being active in the
game is often very fun.
Abstract controls also
cover simple games,
where you tap anywhere on the
screen to make a character move
or jump.
While the interaction
is very, very simple,
this, too is very easy for
people to learn quickly.
Direct controls
occur when you touch
the thing you want
to interact with,
like a button or a slider.
This would happen
in a game where
you were answering
quiz questions,
or casting spells by tapping
on bottles of potion.
Your focus needs to
temporarily be on the device,
but this is a great way to
utilize private information
in your game design.
Virtual controls are
somewhere in between.
You touch something
on the device
to control something
else on the screen.
This would be like a game
pad with virtual buttons.
In this case, the player
needs to understand
how the device
screen is being used,
and if there are specific
gestures, or touch regions,
or different actions
that need to be used.
Once you've decided on
the game's input method,
consider the key
characteristics of the game.
What is the pace?
Is there public versus private
information, like poker?
Is there multi-player?
Being aware of how these
characteristics will affect
game play will help you make
decisions around the input
mechanics and how to
display information
on both the mobile device
and the television.
For visual design, remember
not to fatigue the player
by making them constantly
look up and down.
Design the
television's experience
to be viewed from
across the room.
And remember that
mobile design needs
to be great at a distance
less than arm's length.
It's important to
understand this relationship
between devices, as well as
what to emphasize differently
on each.
How are your devices
and the Google
Cast endpoint going to
connect to each other?
We have two solutions
for you, but each one
has different implications.
First, let's talk about
how Cast applications work.
The first model is what we
call a Receiver Cast game.
An app running on the sender,
which is your mobile device,
connects to receiver
device, which
is any Cast device,
like a Chromecast,
and passes along the ID
of an application to load.
The receiver loads
that application,
written in HMTL5 and
JavaScript from the cloud.
In this model, we recommend
using the Game Manager
APIs for Google Cast, which is
part of the Google Cast SDK.
Game Manager APIs make
it faster and easier
for game developers like
yourself to Cast enable
their apps across
all the devices
we support-- Android,
iOS, Chrome browsers--
and get those devices connected
to a Chromecast or an Android
TV.
We want you to do
what you do best,
and that's make great games.
So we provided this code to help
you get your Cast Game started.
Now, you might be
asking yourself,
we have this giant
TV, a Chromecast,
and we have this amazing
computer in our pocket.
Couldn't we do a
little bit more?
Of course we can.
That's why we created the Remote
Display APIs for Google Cast.
There's millions
of mobile devices
with powerful GPUs and
sensors ready to send
amazing, interactive content to
the largest screen in the home.
With the Remote Display
APIs for Google Cast,
this is now possible.
Remote Display for
Android and iOS
allows app developers
to take full advantage
of the multiscreen
Google Cast model.
Integrating Remote
Display means you
can harness all those
increasingly powerful CPUs
and GPUs in your phone and
build dual display games, where
you use the phone to
render both a local display
and a virtual one.
And we handle displaying
the virtual display
on the large screen
via our Cast protocol.
If you think about it,
this makes total sense.
Why not harness the
power of something
in your hand to send a
great image to the TV?
This allows you to create
games using cutting edge
3D graphics with AAA
effects and HD textures,
and send that amazing
world to the television.
We have many great games like
"Just Dance Now," "Big Web
Quiz," and "SCRABBLE
Blitz," as well
as some sample apps
available, which
utilize the methods we just
covered to make great games.
Just like these games,
your real creative genius
shows itself when you combine
great social multi-player
with the power of mobile
devices and the big screen.
When you do it all right, you
create an entirely new living
room experience,
and players really
get involved in the game.
We've seen this happen with
several great Cast games
already, and we want
yours to be next.
Visit developers.google.com/cast
to learn more.
We provide you with the SDK,
sender SDKs for Android, iOS,
and Chrome, sample apps
that help you get started,
game debugger apps and a
debug UI for the receiver,
UX guidelines for Cast
games, and all the SDK
documentation and reference.
There are so many
unexplored games just
waiting to be created to inspire
and excite millions of gamers.
Go make something awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]